we've all fantasized about jamming an
annoying person cellphone Mexican
free-tailed bats have figured out how to
turn that dream into a reality they Jam
each other's bat signals but not because
they're trying to turn down the volume
they're just trying to steal each
other's meals these bats hang out in
colonies that can number in the millions
but living with so many relatives can
lead to conflict when the colony swarms
out to feed at night competition is
fierce to get an edge the bats Jam the
sensory equipment of nearby buddies then
they can swoop in and steal the meal for
themselves echolocation is basically
biological sonar first you emit a sound
then you listen for an echo which tells
you the position and speed of things
around you and just like sonar bats can
I'll listen in on the same channel at a
frequency mostly above the range of
human hearing this is the sound of a
free-tailed bat getting closer and
closer to its target often a flying
insect I'll still an orderly sound like
a normal echolocation call the audio
pulses speed up because the bat needs to
get more information quickly as it nears
its prey
unfortunately this feeding bottles also
lets nearby hunting bats know that a
competitor is closing in on dinner using
triangulation Aaron Corcoran and William
Connor were able to show that when
nearby bats hear the buzz they swerve
from their flight paths and hone in on
the hunting bat as these interfering
bats close in they actually try to
disrupt the hunt by emitting a jamming
column of their own these vocalizations
swoop up and down like a siren covering
all the frequencies made in the feeding
buzz
the jamming call causes the hunting bat
to lose track of its prey and the
jamming bat takes the opportunity to
snap it up
we don't know whether other types of
bats are using jamming to steal food
from one another but now researchers
know to look out for this new adaptation
in highly competitive feeding
environments
you